and welcome to this
performance governance and audit
committee being held on the 10th of
february 2022
my name is councillor jeannette stiltz
and i am chairman of this committee
members the set up for the meeting has
been designed to mitigate for covid
therefore can i ask all present to work
to the protocols agreed at council on
the 2nd of september 2021
in the interest of member and officer
safety we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up to indicate you
wish to speak i will then invite you at
the appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
recording is dependent upon the correct
use of microphones therefore when
invited to speak please turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
members in the
in addition to the offices in the
chamber we have offices attending
remotely
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda paper regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is the
door behind the top table
i would also like to welcome councillor
stamp and councillor fluker to this
committee
as members
and
mr rubins who is here
for the audit
item two on the agenda is apologies for
absence
berno we have no apologies for absence
everybody is present at this meeting
item three the minutes
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 13th of january
2022 found on pages five to eight are
approved as true and accurate record
i so do move do i have a second for that
motion
thank you councillor
fleming
members do you wish to raise any matters
of accuracy or are you happy to accept
those
minutes
thank you
item 4 declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable procurement interests other
peculiar interests or non-pecuniary
interests related to items of business
on the agenda
having regards to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members you are reminded that you are
also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become
aware should the need arise throughout
the meeting do i have any declarations
of interest
councillor stamp
um yes madam chair uh just that i'm a
member of essex county council
and any agent adams on the agenda
pertaining to that organisation i don't
think there are but if i'll mention it
at the time thank you councillor fleming
thank you chair um non-pecuniary as a
member of essex county council any
anything that might arise thank you
thank you councillor fleming are there
any other interests
no
item five public participation we have
not received any submissions from
members of the public
item 6 is the appointment of vice chair
to point
to the vacancy of vice chairman of
performance governance and audit
committee i would like to nominate
councillor stevens
thank you councillor heard
thank you
thank you so
all the
uh berna we had two
uh nominees councillor fleming and
councillor stevens would you like to do
a call
for
those two members please
i think we've already had
a nomination proposed and seconded i
think we should vote on that and if it
fails we do perhaps go to the second
yeah i was okay the first nomination was
for councillor stevens
so can i ask all those in favor of
councillor stevens do you want this as a
recorded vote as
so i've got
a request for a court recorded vote
burner can you do a recorded vote on
these
so we've had a request for recorded vote
from councillor
and it was stepping deep by councillor
from councillor stevens for councillor
stevens
okay thank you very much chairman
members i will call your names in
alphabetical order can you please um
state um
for against her abstain
counselor stevens as vice chairman
counselor boys
sorry against
edwards
four
mata fleming
that's the keys
against
that's the nun
sorry i have counselor stevens
four
council stamp
thank you i am here
thanks berna against
council of steels
poor thank you members that's four
for the nomination
at five against and no abstentions okay
so i then have a nomination made by
councillor keys for councillor fleming
and that was seconded by councillor hull
thank you thank you chairman uh so
again i will call you name is
alphabetical order can you please stay
clearly for against rap stay in cancer
boys
for
cancer edwards
against
councillor fleming
he's
that's lucas i'm sorry yeah four sorry i
wasn't watching a football
counselor
stamp full
thank you councillor stevens
against
the stilts by epstein
numbers
so that's six four council fleming two
against and two abstentions
thank you
councillor fleming are you happy to be
vice chair of this guy
thank you
thank you very much for that we'll move
on to items madam chair could i just
have confirmation of the first vote
because i thought i heard bernie say
four
four
six uh five against i've got four four
six against i'm my math's
sorry yes it's four or five five against
no extensions for the first vote
i think it was
sorry i think you've got six against
but the second vote was six against
sorry six four
two against and two abstentions for
councillor fleming
can
sorry berna
sorry were you asking for um the council
stephen's vote or the council of fleming
about councillor stevens councillor
stamp wanted just clarification on that
she had six against and four four
sorry that is correct four
four cancer stephens six against
no abstentions counselor fleming six
four
two against and two abstentions thank
you very much but apologies if there's
any confusion there sorry thank you
so i welcome councillor fleming as the
vice chair of this committee so moving
on to item seven the internal audit
report we move to item agenda item seven
the internal audit report and associate
internal order reports from bdo found on
pages 11 to 122 of the meeting pack
mr rubins would you like to present your
reports
thank you good evening um i'm earning my
money tonight so we have eight reports
in front of you um what i propose to do
is actually present them in two batches
so the first batch will be items a
which is the progress report b the
follow-up and item h which is the annual
plan so i'll do those three reports take
any comments or questions and then the
other five which are the main sort of
audit reports i'll take as a second
batch
so if i take you through
uh item a first from page 11 and that
sets out our progress today and we've
obviously got five reports in front of
you today so it's good progress uh the
reports are generally positive obviously
there are some issues which we'll talk
about but on the whole
positive and that's all leading towards
us hopefully a year-end positive head of
internal audit opinion we've got four
more reports to go which we're
work is underway and hopefully they'll
be presented to the june meeting
on item b which starts on page 21 we
have the follow-up of previous
recommendations
you'll see we've covered 12
recommendations there six have been
completed and six are outstanding so
sort of mixed progress there i would say
uh good news on the completed ones it
includes the high priority safeguarding
recommendation which i know members were
concerned about at the time so it's good
that that's been addressed and moved
down um to you know now low risk um on
the overdue ones that includes one
around the environment strategy which
we've talked about many times before and
we're suggesting that actually we
effectively close that one and include
it's part of this uh upcoming years a
review of climate change so we'll
incorporate um the follow-up of that
within that report
and then there are five others that need
to be
action that includes one high priority
around affordable housing so there's
been some action around that but it's
not enough to to complete it and
obviously i would urge officers to
ensure that those remaining actions are
completed as quickly as possible
particularly high priority ones
and then the final report just in this
batch is item h which is from pages 99
onwards and that's our plan for next
year it follows the normal format
it's it's linked to your um your risks
and it's been discussed with officers it
contains a sort of normal number of um
areas you'd expect us to review so a
number around finance and risk for
example um we've also got i think some
some areas that may be of particular
interest so we'll be focusing on the
place directorate and and and the um
uh their their
implementation of their strategy we'll
be looking at flood management again um
again that and and safeguarding both of
which obviously
had issues from previous audits so we'll
be doing more in-depth audits on those
as well as the local development plan
and climate change so some interesting
audits i think hopefully a balanced
program but again i'm happy to take
comments or questions on just those
three items for the time being a b and h
is there any questions counselor heard
um thank you chairman uh on page 24 um
you speak uh it says that the the
remaining four
recommendations relate to flood
management
were all overdue
um can we know what what the issue was
and why that why that
why that didn't happen please
and also on page 25 uh affordable
housing didn't receive the sign off
and you're saying that the focus should
be on the
2223 not the 2021.
um
but if that one if that one wasn't done
what's
stopping
the 22 23 what was in place that it
didn't happen that would make the 2023
one late
and also on the safeguarding
there's two forms
uh c1a and sethsaf1
and i think it said that you should use
one or the other
what is the difference between the two
forms please
i may need some help from officers on
some of these questions i think the
flood management one from memory
included a number around um sort of
partnership working strategy attending
various cross-council groups
um
and i think there are a number of
actions outstanding around that um that
people are working on um but i'd have to
look up the detail of that um i'm not
sure i quite understood the one on
affordable this is about the work has
begun on the updated plan for 22 23
are you was the question what happened
to 2122 well i i understand that uh
it's
looking backwards but but it wasn't the
21-22 wasn't completed
what's stopping the 2223 not being
completed what what factors stopped it
being signed off
i think that that would be one for
officers too i haven't got mr swords on
the
line if you would like to come in
good evening good evening councillor
still good evening councillors
um apologies from damian geller he's not
able to attend tonight but i've spoken
to him yesterday and the issue was
collating the information he's in the
process now of collating the the
information he needs with regards to the
affordable housing and he's on target
and he's looking to have that completed
by april
so it was just a matter of collating the
information i already hold the records
on my master
development spreadsheet on affordable
housing
which feeds into the business plan
so i have to do that anyway every year
which i then have to report back in
april to government on the delta return
forms
so it's just a pure a simple matter of
damien obtaining all the information in
the format he needs it's the business
plan to be pulled back
on this issue
counseling well i'm not sure that
answered the question what was it that
that enabled the 2020 21 22 not to be
completed that we hope that 22 23 will
be
please
i mean i i i believe it was just the
information done in getting the
information into the business plan i
believe that's what was what held it up
um
but i understand at the moment that he's
working on that and it's just a case of
reporting it i think
okay thank you and the other question
was about the um the forms c1i and sets
f1 what is the difference please
um i i know that they they do serve
slightly different purposes i believe
they're around
reporting on incidents of safeguarding
incidents to um you know other
uh
bodies local authorities and so on i
need to come back to you on exactly what
the difference is between the two unless
one of the officers knows well that
would be mystical mr holmes uh sorry i
won't be able to give that clarification
this evening absolutely right it's it's
two forms of safeguarding reporting form
but there is a slight nuance between the
two but um they're both in place now but
uh i can't provide that to the committee
in writing after i was gonna say can i
ask that that is sent out to the
committee so that everybody has the
answer to that question
well just the point that i wanted to
make chairman is that the the
the the audit said
um
the council should ensure that both the
c-1a and sets a form are in place as
opposed to having one or the other
although both forms are in place and
both forms clearly were in place
they weren't both being completed so i
just wanted to know
how we're ensuring they are going to be
completed now
would that that would be a question for
mr geller who's not here tonight
so we will get mr geller to send out an
answer to that question councillor stamp
you put your hand up i did thank you
chairman um i just wondered if there was
any uh mitigating circumstances why they
are in red was it to do with kovid is it
due to lack of resources
um i think it's i've looked at the whole
of this report and i know we've taken
them uh bit by bit but the areas of
concern i think it's really important
that this council forgive me because
it's the first time on this committee
for such a long long time but it's
really important that it's put under cut
into context so is are what are the
mitigating circumstances why the
affordable housing is in roads and the
safeguarding safeguarding i do recall
from watching these meetings online has
been an area of concern for this council
for for a long time now
and i know certain councillors
have been
shall we say chomping at the bit to try
and make sure the safeguarding policy
came into fruition and was done sooner
than later um so my question is madam
chair what are the mitigating
circumstances if there are any why they
hadn't why they're in red and why they
haven't come to council as they should
have done previously thank you mr rubens
well again that's what i think that's
more for opposition for us we just
monitor it and report on it
give me chair if i'm asking the wrong
questions i apologize but i think it's
important that to people to understand
what this report is saying and the
auditors are producing we need to know
what's behind this because not everybody
knows yeah thank you if an officer has
to answer then please i think the
officer that has to answer is mr geller
who's
not here tonight madam chair i think he
has a boss i would think his his boss
might be able to help
chairman i prefer mr glad to give you
that full answer but you're absolutely
right there are a number of
circumstances behind if you look at the
the base this is about sort of a
technical use of a form and making sure
we're communicating with our staff
correctly and using the right form we do
have obviously an internal intranet
that's where these forms are located and
there has been some work over the last
few months to actually tidy and work on
that but i think this delay could give
you that fuller answer than i can this
evening
chris yeah so i don't think we'll also
address it you mentioned uh about it
being read in there the safeguarding
absolutely there i think on page 25.
can i just interrupt just the
safeguarding yeah it's just the thing
the things in red to see if there was
any anything that identified why they're
in road that's all it wasn't just
safeguarded yeah okay thank you so i
mean that that is
if it helps that that is um a judgment
of the internal audit when they pick up
uh a recommendation they flag whether
it's a high medium or low risk one if
it's a high risk one where they feel um
it needs to be implemented urgently then
they will flag it as high in using the
red category and so that's why the color
difference is red because it's urgent uh
obviously on that page 25 it's got the
completed ones
under it that safeguarding where it is
red that that is now completed the
hybrid one
okay
councillor fleming
thank you chair um i just wanted through
you to ask mr swords about um reporting
for affordable housing he referenced an
april report
so i was interested to learn whether
that was for central government
and how often
uh he or mr geller report into clt
whether it's court quarterly monthly
thank you okay
mr serge do you want to answer
i think you're answering part of that
question and probably mr holmes the
other part
yes the the delta reform the sorry the
delta form um every council has to
report on that in the country in april
that's a requirement by government of
every council
and equally i also report quarterly on
the affordable housing
returns into uh policy which then feeds
into i believe clt yes thank you
mr holmes did you wanna thank you yes we
do receive quarterly reports and we also
operate the balance scorecard and also
we also look for exception reporting as
well so on a number of occasions it gets
reported in
councillor stevens
thank you chair um sticking with
affordable housing and page 25 i'm a bit
confused to see something mark down has
completed which is the strategic housing
board meetings to be reinstated we have
had one
and that was in december sorry in
september which means that the following
one should have been in december and
here we are sort of coming up to mid feb
and we haven't had a meeting and there
isn't one scheduled
i have asked several times to the staff
for this meeting to be properly
scheduled with the calendar of all the
dates not just one put in the place
and it still hasn't happened but it's
marked here as completed and i don't
really understand that thank you
mr sauce can you answer that one
yeah i know that mr geller is aware of
this and we are looking to i believe
he's looking to send out the dates as to
when we're going to have the next
meeting i know he had to uh deal with
just in terms of reference issues and
once that's completed he's sending all
that out with some dates and with the
next agenda
it's just that you know we've been under
extreme pressure um just before
christmas
um with the latest requirements from
government on um rough sleepers and
everybody in again which has put the
housing department under you know
further strain
but we are there he is aware of it and
he is going to be getting back to those
members on that board
very very shortly
councillor stevens did you want to come
back please if i may thank you yes i do
understand that and i do understand the
pressures you're under and i think
you're choosing the right priorities
what i don't understand is why it's
marked as complete on here please thanks
mr rubies
um
yes perhaps you could argue it's been
slightly generous but the whole point of
the finding was to say and you know
terms of reference should be agreed for
the new meetings and they should start
again and obviously they have started
again but i take the point that
obviously they need to take place on a
regular basis
you're still looking a bit confused
cancer stevens
well
yes what can i say it's not complete
really is it having one meeting
isn't
a completed thing there was one meeting
i think this needs to remain open and
stay on the report so we can track it
for next time please thank you
okay well i'm happy to make that change
yeah
okay lovely is there any other questions
on those
sections that
mr rivens has gone through
no mr rubens did you want to
okay so we'll move on to the five
detailed reports um so that's uh items c
to g um
so the first one is on um the policy
review and that's come out well
substantial on design moderate on
effectiveness uh generally we thought
good controls there there's a central
database of policies
policies are authorized and there's a
process for that
the one issue we had was and we found a
couple of policies out of date and some
minor documentation issues so
recommendations be made around that and
the council doesn't have a sort of cent
one person who's responsible for all
their policies so that does mean it's
going to be for each service area to
make sure they keep those up to date and
but that will be reviewed as part of the
service planning process
second report is on strategic
performance in community
and again that's come out well
substantial on design moderate on
effectiveness uh we thought that there
was evidence of really good stakeholder
engagement strong relationships uh clear
progress reporting um again one
main finding which was really around the
need to have uh more detailed action
plans where things are falling behind
target and we saw a role for this
committee to receive those action plans
when there is a need to
address issues so that's been accepted
and i believe will be taken forward
um so the next report is on main
financial systems um so that's uh
item
e
um
so um this one again is a positive
report substantial on design moderate on
effectiveness um we thought there were
good controls generally across the range
of areas we looked at which included
general ledger system access budget
management and treasury management
four low priority areas really mainly
minor documentation points like making
sure there's evidence of review of
reconciliations and things like that but
actually you know we think on the main
the controls are operating well
and i think that's a good result for the
council
so then we have report number four which
is item f on page 67 i.t strategy and
transformation
that's given moderate for design and
moderate for effectiveness uh the
council has an i.t strategy it has a
clear and good governance structure
there is clearly a process there to
review individual projects as they
happen i think our push was really
around two areas around making trying to
have more detail within the it
strategies it's clearer to see how it
links to the corporate strategy
and that you can see some detailed
milestones behind it
and secondly more evidence to show that
when you have these forms that you're
using to um monitor and approve projects
that those are being used
and
you know retained so we can see that
that's happening and escalated when
necessary to the management team and
you'll see from the management responses
perhaps we haven't got complete
agreement around that i think the
council's view is that as a smaller
council you know some of the things that
we're asking for might be seem to be a
little bit onerous um but they they are
good practice and obviously
i think overall the council's got
reasonable arrangements and you do
monitor your projects carefully um but
we think some of the areas we've we've
suggested might strengthen the controls
further
and then the last um report is
management property uh which is item g
on pages 83 to 98 this was moderate
moderate i would say possibly uh the you
know the weakest though in terms of the
the areas that we looked at
so the council's got a central register
of assets
it does sort of regular monitoring of
costs and budgets against that
but as you'll see we've raised a number
of areas one being high priority which
is that the council doesn't have a
detailed uh process at the moment for
monitoring when repairs are required uh
on its various uh assets um
we've suggested also you need more
formal policies and procedures
around sort of use of assets there's a
need for
a sort of regular review as to whether
you're making the best use of your
assets um and also we found in terms of
the debt recovery process around this
not all of the um arrangements were
being followed so there wasn't a
standard letter sent out by a certain
date each time so some of the processes
won't be followed so all of those points
have been accepted by officers i think
there's been a number of resource issues
and system issues as to why these things
haven't been done before but we have got
an action plan agreed as to how they
could be addressed in future
so quite a lot there in front of you and
again happy to take comments or
questions
councillor heard
um thank you chairman i'm on page 36
at the moment
um and this relates to uh well 35
actually
this talks about the
uh
the the 10 policies taken from the
from the council's suite of policies
um it does say in all ten policies it
didn't clearly state who the owner was
but provided detail as to who prepared
the policy
the response was
uh that
and this is on page 36 each officer will
be responsible for updating their
respective policy um but it doesn't say
that it would say who the officer is on
there
so
if in in the one case and i appreciate
that it wasn't an important case but in
one case
the officer responsible no longer worked
for the council so how would how is this
going to be managed
mr dobson
um
there will be a checklist to check the
policies and we're going to put a link
into the um
database to ensure that
it highlights which ones need to be
reviewed and if there's missing data so
that through that process we can we can
make sure these gaps are filled and we
check what's due within the year
thank you thank you
councillor let me
thank you chair um i wanted to talk
about um report g um management of
property um i remember back in the day
and when i first joined the council we
had the asset management working group
um
[Music]
i i feel quite strongly that that should
be
reconstituted
i actually thought it was a very good
working group
so i wanted officers thoughts on on
whether that could be actioned thank you
mr dobson
um
happy to answer broadly and maybe
i think the reason why that that ceased
was because there was duplication
between the asset management
um in terms of taking those goes forward
so
rather than trying to hurt that i think
that's
thank you chairman yes yes we did have
that group for a number of years
actually which operated and members had
a regular opportunity to talk about uh
property um i think there's no reason
why that couldn't be reconstituted and
that might be an opportunity to focus in
on some of these um audit activities as
well so um monitoring could be true you
know progress could be tracked um but
that is something we could discuss and
putting that back
counselor fluker you put your hand up
yeah thank you chairman um
yeah i can remember the asset management
group and i actually thought that uh it
was very worthwhile um and german this
something along these lines i mentioned
the strategy and resources committee
um
we don't seem to present an asset
register anymore to members
and we always used to and there are a
lot of members on this council now who i
know do not know what assets this
council owns and and that register
really should be presented somewhere and
i think it dovetails into this nicely so
i hope that's perhaps something that uh
mr rubinson it's nice to see you again
mr rubin's although can i say you i i i
think i enjoyed our meetings in the
afternoon when this committee met better
and i'm sure you do as well um so yeah i
think you know i think that's something
maybe for stretching resources to get
the asset management register and i
think from that we we also try to
understand
you know where the council's owed money
uh where it's trying to move forward and
it's acting proactively to make sure
that all of our tenants and our assets
are producing the proper amount of
income and and as for the corporate
projects committing asset management
committees i mean
clearly one is a one is a futures
committee
and the other is a is a now and here and
now committee and i i can sort of see
them still being separate in my mind
because you should have your blue skies
uh thinkers on your projects where we're
going to go forward with new corporate
projects
to work out where we're going to close
the budget gap because this is what it's
all about and the presence really just
to make sure that we're maintaining our
assets properly so i'm i always get a
bit confused uh mr rubin's uh makes his
recommendations uh i'm not sure that's
the sort of thing that he would
recommend but i definitely think it
should be on our radar and i think if we
took all of that into consideration and
i think this would help a lot with with
sorting these issues out but i'm i'm i
am uh very comfortable with mr holmes
comment in relation to the asset
management group being reconvened but
i'm not quite sure it was unconstituted
anyway but i'll no doubt you'll report
back to us all
i'm not sure if i like these masks
because i don't know if you're agreeing
with me or not
did
is it a proposal for the snl committee
to take that one forward
chairman i'm just trying to reflect on
where that asset management working
group came from originally whether it
came through council or whether it came
through um snr
i think it was a council and set up for
members of uh from council i recall but
i think chairman if you know me i think
it was
with um council so that we could you
know we could bring the best skill sets
together for that particularly would you
like to make a recommendation
i would propose that
mr holmes uh looks into this and and
hopefully we bring a report back to
council and we we actually
set up
an asset management committee and i
think also that would then take some
pressure off your corporate projects
because so they can focus on where they
need to go because at the moment we keep
hearing that there's a lot of stuff
going on in the background but
i don't see much of it being reported to
communicate
your proposal is that mr holmes takes
this forward and hopefully sets up a
asset management
working group through
i think generally with respect i think
mr holmes will be bringing forward a
report for council to decide uh and i'm
sure it will be heavily weighted in
favor of doing just that and i'm sure so
hopefully hopefully someone will support
my proposal thank you thank you i was
then asked if there's a support
councillor fleming you're happy to
second that proposal
is this committee in favor of that
proposal
okay thank you councillor fleming
actually thank you chair for interest
for members there is actually a map i
believe that uh has uh the register
it's a register of assets held by essex
county council and by malden district
council
i think it's called the essex land and
property um i can
find the link for members i'm happy to
and you can sort of scroll around and
see where
who owns what thank you is that helpful
for you
yeah
that would be lovely if you could email
the link to the members of this
committee and
councillor stamp yeah sorry chad do we
not have an asset list i i mean i've got
some old copies because you know i'm
like i'm a paper person and
i'm sure we've already we've got that
just because it's not been brought to
this committee it doesn't mean to say we
don't have it
um and and i'm sure it's updated because
i'm often in dispute with what we're
supposed to earn and what the council
isn't supposed to own aren't we mr
holmes
i was going to defer to mr leslie and
then i'll come back to you council of
luca
yeah we keep a list in finance as well i
believe the gis mapping um software as
well which could also help identify the
lands we've got a pacific officer
to do that uh now as well so there's a
couple of sources uh we can pull on uh
within the council to identify that
thank you
council stamp did you want to come back
before i get to cancel a fluke no no i
didn't if council folk is still talking
about that subject i'll wait because
i've got a different question all right
i think just for clarity i think that
you know i think this we always used to
have a list of assets and and i think
it's important that all members actually
it's brought to all members attention
whether it goes to the asset management
uh working group to consider or whether
it goes to strategy and resources once a
year um i'm not quite sure in my mind
but that's the point i was making but i
know these things are available but i
think we need to make sure the members
are aware of them sorry and i'll give
way now for the new subject because i
understood it i will leave that with mr
holmes and mr leslie to
sort out for you councillor stamp did
you want to i'd i'd just like to ask a
question please um where are we now on
it says r26 page 69 failure to deliver
channelship uh mr holmes knows i'll
constantly go on about this um because
about the um
channel shift was to do the telephone
calls and customer engagement um could i
ask mr rubins what he actually found and
if he wouldn't mind running through that
i know you're going to say it's on the
papers but i'd like to discuss it
because i think many many people
including you madam chairman is actually
very interested on this interest thank
you
um well sorry to disappoint you but this
this report was all that is saying that
is the risk that the council has on its
risk register and that it's a kind of
related risk to the i.t strategy so we
didn't do a specific piece of work in
this instance around championship we
have done on other occasions and i think
we may do in the future but that wasn't
really about that we were really just
focusing on the strategy as a whole so
sorry i can't i can't comment on this
since jen can anybody help does anybody
go back to mr
there because it's dobson risk
the the the audix reflect that before
mr rubin said we've actually over
achieved on our championship compared to
um the targets
that we set and i think we've reported
that in the balanced scorecard and i
think we've reported it through
um
the copied um pandemic as well when we
highlighted that that had been part of
what had driven um the championship but
for more access via online systems so
we're actually ahead
in terms of the targets that we have to
to
we've achieved more than we've targeted
chairman i would like to come back
because i think that was actually
debated and discussed it's maybe not for
this committee but i would like to see
those figures because i certainly have
disputed them and and i don't think i
got a report back when i was quoting it
through mr holmes because i can't
remember what committee i raised it at
now and you said you would come back to
me and and if we wanted to put more
resources in it would come to council
and i don't believe anything has so i
i'd be just interested in that please
because it's a major concern for
residents who still cannot get through
on the phone or online so thank you mr
holmes feminist i think this is going to
be wrapped within the customer strategy
um some members will be the customer
strategy will come to members and that's
where you'll see some choices around you
know how we do things and how we want to
continue with uh working the ways
perhaps we are now and that's where
members will get the opportunity to
debate but i'd be more than happy to dig
out some background details and share
with members in the meantime thank you
that's appreciated thank you is there
any other questions for mr rubin's
or offices
no thank you
thank you mr ribbins thank you for your
report members there is a recommendation
and the recommendation committee
considers comments and approves the
following little one internet audit
progress report november 2021
little two follow-up of recommendations
report november 2021
little three policy review report
january 2022
little four strategy strategic
performance community report january
2022
five
main financial systems report january
2022
little six it strategy and
transformation report january 2022
little seven management of property
report january 2022
and little eight draft internal audit
plan
2022-2023 and strategic plan 2022-2025
do i have a seconder for those
recommendations councillor fleming thank
you are you all happy to accept those
recommendations
thank you that's that's accepted
so thank you mr rubins for that very
in-depth report
moving on
um
agenda item eight
appointment to outside bodies we move to
agenda item eight found on pages one two
three two one two four
the recommendation is found on page one
two three of the report
and the recommendation is the committee
appoints one member representative to
serve on the malden
citizens of vice bureau liaison
committee do i have a recommendation
remember to sit on that at the moment
it's councillor fleming and councillor
stevens
i need one more
thank you do i have a second of a
council of course
are you seconding yourself
um i don't know whether the conflicts of
interest because my mother used to work
down there as a
secretary or sleep well i know she
hasn't worked because obviously it's
been shut since coving but
i
yeah but it's not the one-to-one stuff
as much as what she organized people
coming in but i i am happy to sit on it
if there's not a conflict of interest i
would do that okay um i will just check
is there a conflict of interest with
that
i don't think there is but i will check
back
mr dobson
okay
so thank you mr casey you are
the representative on that committee
thank you very much councillors
um and also i need one representative on
the museum in the in the park outside
body for the remainder of this municipal
year so do i have
a
a member for that recommendation
i have councillor stevens is already on
it i need one more person
counselor keys even knows where it is i
think it'd be perfectly closed
i think he'd be perfectly placed to uh
to do that but sadly it's not something
i can i could take on at the moment but
i i do actually wonder why it falls upon
this committee to a point to the museum
you know i know these appointments has
to come somewhere but i would have
thought that council would have been
you know council should have come to it
i think it comes from when this
committee used to have a or we used to
run
the museum
in that now we just put liaison member
on to a meeting
yeah
gentlemen i can't help thinking that
perhaps you know i can see everybody
chomping at the bit led by councillor
who's to take this role up but i'm sure
there must be somebody on on within the
council who who would aspire to this and
and so maybe it might be something to go
back to council when we can add it to mr
holmes's ever-growing list
mr holmes mr dobson do you have any
i mean counselor keys has been
recommended by councillor fluker
councillor boyce you put your hand
no i i was just going to say that um
the museum in the park is one of our
assets that we were talking about
earlier and it is the reason for why we
have um some representatives or or two
on it
um but my personal view is i think it
should be somebody from malden
um
uh stevens you've sat on one meeting so
far
no we've had quite a few i would think
about three or four oh well let's see i
think maybe three
so at the moment
i need
because it was uh councillor nunn was on
it
and
i propose the chairman chairman
thank you i am quite happy to take it if
nobody else wants to do that i will do
it
thank you
all right thank you have you got that
burner
just gonna check with ben thank you
chairman yes i have thank you thank you
item number nine on the agenda any other
items or business that the chairman
decides are urgent there are none item
10 closure of the meetings members thank
you for your contributions this evening
i now draw the meeting to a close at 8
00 uh 2018
p.m as the members the meeting is now
revised not to enter into any further
discussion and please leave the meeting
via the exit door behind the top table
bearing in mind social distancing thank
you